welcome back everybody to drew's
birthday celebration we have another
surprise we're just we can't stop and i
have no idea what's happening no you
really really don't now i'm going to
give you some clues for our next guest
are you ready okay you first met over
coffee
she's been a real angel in cameroon life
and you may know her as poo poo yeah
it's cameron cameron diaz
[Applause]
we speak english for the rest of us oh
that's how we talk i know that's how we
say hello and goodbye and it lasts a
long time can you know what we're saying
yeah cameron of course you had to be
here because as long as i've known drew
with just a few years i've always known
one thing and that is that cameron aka
poopoo is her very very very very
closest friend what are some of your
favorite birthday memories and true
memories
we have spent many birthdays together
um usually we have you know we get to
actually be together and by the way i
wish you could tell by my background i
am not backstage pretending to do
or it's not blue right now usually we're
together somehow we always get together
we're not big gift givers
we're more about experience so we always
try to go someplace and do something
with the girls and be together and cook
and eat and hang and stay up all night
and just have the best there's the
couple those pictures is back to back
years one was and that we went to down
to the caribbean and then the next year
we were in the hamptons at the beach so
we had like two very different beach
experiences we've been to hawaii too for
one of uh the birthdays
hawaii we've done we've done a lot we've
gone everywhere all over the world
together and she's still the only person
who's uh convinced me
well that convinced me she we like i
don't like co-sleeping with anyone it's
a thing i don't know why but it's just
my thing if it's like a lover then
obviously that's different but no
friends no i will sleep in a bathtub
i'll sleep but i slept on a pool table
like you name it but but this one
you spoon with poo poo oh my gosh
yes and we've lived together for periods
of time
and
um been roommates and i've slept in a
tent while like my fever was breaking on
a chilean mountain in a thunderstorm and
like patagonia yeah i mean we've been
everywhere together can you guys please
explain the nicknames because you have
i've so i mean can you i think that's a
real question
well it started out as like classic boy
humor
and then it just evolved into a true
term of endearment and then it just
stuck when we're at a restaurant she'll
you know say to the waiter ask poopoo
what she wants some people
cameron do you like the nickname or is
it like one of those things where if you
complain about it then you're definitely
never getting rid of it i call each
other poo poo i call her poo poo she's
in my phone
yeah no
it's we love it and she's my daughter
frankie's godmother and yet still it's
poo poo and
it just it will never change it's
forever there we are pepe and papel what
is parmigiano parmigiano
parmigiano
okay
parmigiano okay you know what you guys
you just do you
can have a whole conversation only
saying parmigiano yes and we can evoke
every action and emotion all in
parmigiano well you guys you obviously
speak your own language which we love
now charlie's angels of course is
everyone's favorite movie i saw that the
sex and the city ladies are getting back
together it did make me think could
there be
a charlie's angel reunion would you guys
ever
i'm getting an amen from the crowd here
i'm glad that people feel that way you
know i'll be grannies and inner tubes
so
you know that we can do anything and
everything as long as we're together i
have a whole life to live with you
i always say never say never and i feel
the same way there's never a time where
we're not going to
be connected or
you know consider something together
but you know what i really just i was
just watching obviously the segment
before the segments before this
and watching you with david and
knowing how long your guys's friendship
has been and
just
all of everything that's being shared
about you it's just so beautiful it's
just watching your whole life and seeing
what you've accomplished and seeing all
of the light that you have shared with
the world since you were just this
little bitty child um i can't wait to
just grow old with you and to experience
the rest of our life together because
it's truly one of the great joys of my
life is our friendship
and when i think about you i literally
i'll cry because i just think you're so
special and to celebrate you is the
absolute like
every year it's one of my favorite times
of the year is to get to celebrate you
you've made me a better person my whole
life and you've seen me through
everything ugly beautiful lost
life and universe
getting your bed is like literally i
just didn't want to sleep on the floor
all night holding your hand from the
ground i know because that was a bad
breakup and you
you
and
and yet every breakup was okay because
we were always there and
true friendship is when somebody sees
your flaws and demands that you fix them
and they're your mirror
and they really really know you so the
fact that you love me means more to me
than anything because gosh darn do you
know every little thing about me and i
know everything about you and i love you
so much and you always make me want to
be a better person whether it's when
you're mad because i'm leaving my lights
on for the energy of the planet or if my
behavior needs a real room check and
it's time for me to grow up again and
everything in between
i love you more
you are what true friendship is all
about and i just i can't wait to grow
old with you too because we're going to
be old together
i know it's charlie's grannies yeah we
just came up with the concept
my attempt at some sort of weird re like
reveal turning around is like is if you
don't know it's me
who could that be
you know she actually sent something for
you we're in your kitchen if it's in
your fridge over here a little well
you'll see
something i hope it's her wine aveline
is it aveline it's avalyn
by the way allow me to use this moment
to talk about cameron's amazing wine
line but
cut that part out because you don't need
to talk about my wine this is just to
toast you excuse me that's my sister
you're talking about and i'm really
proud because also you're trying to put
something out there that's better for
people and everybody loves it a toast to
you drew i love you savannah i love you
delicious by the way cameron send me a
case i love it
[Music]